now I want you to to get good rest what  if I have a bad dream I'm sure we can  handle any dream you have what if I  dream that you sent us away into the  dark and me hurt really hurt what I'm so  sad is scared of the dark out there that  I could poison in me  for years and on earth until my blood  turns into poison and my heart breaks  right in half and I can't feel anything  happy  I can't stand it anymore and I I have to  die  and time on a silver table  it's my job iron cut  [Music]  did you wake us up from a dream like  that  we're not like any other family we're  different  because of where we grew up  Hill House  your mother she was not crazy  neither was her sister neither is her  brother neither are you  it's that house  [Music]  you don't have to worry now sweetie that  really bad dream  of course I'd wake  [Music]  you